this is joanna puzzo feline welfare
manager at bassy cats and dogs home and
this handsome shy little lad is kip
they're joining us today to take a look
at gaming's new favorite furry feline in
stray so they're grooming each other
they're greeting each other with those
cheer up calls
this little kind of squeaks and things
like that and that just means that
they're quite a bonded sort of social
group
cat's jumping on the piano of course
oh my gosh this is horrible
i hope it's okay
please do check all the links in the
description down there you'll be able to
find links to batsy cats and dogs homes
website as well as their donation and
support pages and even a place where you
could sign up to adopt adorable little
kip right over to joanna
yeah it looks like this this chap is
oh having a little game with his friend
and i assume that these this is probably
a miniature kind of colony of stray cats
that are all living together yeah so a
little bit of play behavior there and
what's interesting is all of these cats
if you can see with one exception i
think there's a black cat but they're
all ginger or ginger and white which is
really common when it comes to colonies
feral colonies because genetically
they're all sort of you know quite
similar so you often see these colonies
of cats all looking the same color the
same color variations that's really
quite common and you'll also see what's
called this aloe grooming behavior so
they're grooming each other they're
greeting each other with those churro
calls
those little kind of squeaks and things
like that and that just means that
they're quite a bonded sort of social
group and they're all quite familiar
with each other that's usually the kind
of makeup of those feral colonies also
important to note most most ginger cats
are male um it doesn't mean you don't
get female gingers but i'm going to
assume that this this chap is male i
think he doesn't really have a name does
he bless him so now it looks like he's
establishing a sort of territorial
marker there both chemically with the
scent glands from his paw pads
establishing that scent on the tree but
also a very striking visual marker to
denote that this is his territory this
is his space again horizontal scratching
very similar he's saying this is his
familiar territory his face and also
sharpening his claws there's a little
bit of maintenance there as well when
they do
claw sharpen and i know this isn't
always a an attractive feature when cat
scratch furniture and things like that
you can do things to mitigate that like
scratching posts really tall vertical
scratching posts so the cat is able to
fully scratch and fully extend and it's
just really important to provide those
for cats in a home environment so they
don't destroy furniture and things like
that and they can
show that natural behavior of scratching
and depositing their scents and that
just establishes that familiarity in
their environment so they're much more
comfortable
so again most cats are quite good at
avoiding knocking things off so this
probably is intentional when you do see
cats knocking things off of shelves
there's a little bit of purposeful
behavior there with with knocking those
items off
that's quite a defensive move he just
made um he doesn't know what this is and
cats are designed to have that fear
response when they come into contact
with something that they don't know it's
a natural survival mechanism anything
that's alien or foreign to them could
potentially present a danger so that
jumping back is you know a way of him
kind of creating some distance between
him and whatever it is that could be a
danger to him right so he's again
adopting that very defensive posturing
with the dilated pupils that hissing and
the ears flat and what he's doing is
running away so a cat's chosen form to
um cope with something that's scary or a
danger to their survival is to run so
cats will adopt one of the four f's as a
strategy to maintain their survival so
that's flight fight uh freeze or fidget
and so anything that could put them in
danger like fighting something and
becoming injured they want to avoid so
he's gonna he's gonna go for flight to
get away from those little flea-looking
creatures and keep himself safe and that
little scratch there is probably a
displacement behavior where he's
actually not itchy but it's a
de-stressor it's a d arousal technique
where just a quick groom or a quick
scratch it can just de-arouse them and
kind of just bring those stress levels
down a little bit so they can kind of
take a deep breath so it's actually not
a functional behavior but rather just a
displacement behavior to kind of take
stock and and and just kind of take a
breath
okay so i think this is the little
backpack the little little kind of
harness that gets put on him so this is
actually something a bit tricky because
most cats don't appreciate having
something on them like unfortunately you
know there are people who will put
clothes or you know harnesses on their
cats and just because cats really like
to be in control of their environment
and what's happening to them this can be
very aversive and quite uncomfortable
and that's why he's adopting that quite
low down kind of crawling posture
because he wants to take it off so we
it's not something we would recommend
putting anything like a little backpack
on a cat or harness or anything like
that it's something that for the video
game it is quite cute and i suppose it
has a purpose but generally cats
wouldn't appreciate something like this
also i wouldn't recommend putting your
cat in a bucket and sending him kind of
parasailing down an alleyway um it's
very very cute you do see those internet
videos of people who live in high rise
flats and they'll lower a basket down
and the cat will jump in and come up but
that's a very you know context specific
situation so most cats generally don't
like zooming down uh you know on on a
zip line like that i would imagine
interestingly this this cat is he's
rubbing up against these these robots
that he's come across again they have
very strong scent glands along their
flanks their sides and so what he's
doing is depositing that scent to sort
of create some familiarity um with that
object or that person basically saying
okay so you know you're familiar to me
you're not a threat i just want to make
you know make it clear that we're sort
of on the same social footing and cats
do this with their owners or somebody
you know they first meet if they don't
feel that they're a threat if they're
quite comfortable with them quite
familiar so it's a really nice behavior
it's lovely grading behavior that cats
will adopt when they when they meet
someone
[Music]
so yeah so oftentimes you see cats
curled up like this and um it's
oftentimes it's feigned sleeping which
means they're not actually completely
falling asleep they're still very
vigilant and this is because they're
both a predator and a prey species so
they always have to be aware of their
surroundings to make sure there's no
danger you can see his ears are pricked
upright kind of just listening for
anything going on in his immediate
surroundings and again that random
vocalizing while he's sleeping there
isn't generally something cats do i
think it was added in just probably for
cuteness effects they will vocalize
towards individuals or towards their
owner to try to get food or treats
attention things like that
cats jumping on the piano of course
you see a lot of cats do this and they
kind of freak out and jump off because
the noise is so startling
[Music]
walking on keyboards that was something
you know during lockdown people working
from home i think a lot of cats got into
trouble for and that is generally cats
you know sometimes want to be involved
in what's going on sleeping on laptops
it's a nice warm surface near their
owner so a lot of cats will do that and
you know get in the way
so this is interesting because generally
most cats won't opt to put a paper bag
on their head i don't know if he meant
to do that but obviously he looks quite
distressed and he can't see again as a
prey species they need to be always in
control of their environment and always
on the lookout for danger so putting a
paper bag on a cat's head is definitely
not something that we would recommend i
imagine this is maybe just to show cats
can get into sticky situations and maybe
it looks funny from the outside but
really it's uh it could be quite scary
and not not very nice for the cat you
can't see where he's going turning
around in circles
okay
i wouldn't recommend uh putting a cat on
a little go-kart there and sending him
careening down oh my gosh this is
horrible
oak is okay
always limping
oh bless him
so cats are very very very good at
hiding or disguising pain or when
they're injured or ill so he must
actually be quite in a lot of pain to be
showing that lymph um the reason that
they hide any injury illness is again
because they are an independent species
and they don't have other
pack individuals around to take care of
them if they do fall ill and if they
show any weakness then they're easy
pickings for predator this all stems
from their ancestor the african wild cat
who they've they're descended from and
living out in sort of northern african
plains there and they would be extremely
vulnerable if they were to show that
weakness so he will usually hide it but
interestingly this poor guy does seem to
have a bit of a limb so that fall must
have really
done a bit of damage bless him
[Music]
yes the old cat getting involved in the
board game they don't have boundaries
you know if they want to get involved
and anything like that could potentially
be something for them to play with they
often see play items um you know in
different things cardboard boxes cats
love cardboard boxes it's uh you know a
little hidey hole for them it's
something to investigate those natural
exploratory behaviors that cats will
often show in the wild and cardboard
boxes are just great to provide for
entertainment you know scrunching up
some paper in there and throwing a few
treats and it's a natural like puzzle
feeder for them a natural kind of
foraging feeder which is really good at
tapping into their natural
behaviors
yeah so the cat getting under people's
feet um this does happen and you know
oftentimes they do that when they're
rubbing against your legs and you're
you've got you know your hands full of
something and they'll trip you up and
that's them just you know wanting to rub
against you and establishing their
territory this robot is probably playing
it up a little bit i think maybe he's
the uh he's the issue here and they
don't intentionally do this you know
cats don't intentionally try to trip
people up they're not certainly not
trying to do that and cause injury i
think he's just doesn't realize that he
is in the way
[Music]
i mean the game it's it's really quite
ingenious because who whoever made the
game they really picked up on a lot of
um very natural cat behaviors like aloe
grooming and aloe rubbing with
individuals in his social group they've
also included some nice subtle behaviors
like the pupils dilating when he's you
know quite vigilant those ears turning
and the defensive posturing also the
vocalizing it's really sweet and really
nice and um yeah they definitely have
done their research and i guess the only
thing i would say is it's it's such a
lovely game and i think it's really
lovely to showcase stray cats um just
coming from battersea you know we do get
quite a few strays into us all looking
for their homes as well as cats that are
um you know brought into us by their
owners and you know if you do want to
support battersea by just taking a look
at our website and any cats available
for homing that would be fantastic if
you do want to know a little bit more
about cat behavior as well we have a
huge suite of feline literature on our
website or just advice around any issues
with your cats but i think just to
just to round up they really have
captured quite a lot of kind of little
behaviors there with with this cat and i
think it's just really sweet what
they've achieved and it seems really
popular so they definitely have done
something right there
[Music]
you